Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
This week's The N-ko Show has started!
It's Friday already.
A week goes by so quickly.
By the way,
the tea swiss roll I had the other day was absolutely delicious.
It was sold at a pastry shop near my home, and I bought a piece of it.
It was so delicious
that I want to buy and eat
a whole roll the next time.
Well then,
let's start The N-ko Show!
Weekly Favorites!
I will share my recommendations based on my personal picks again.
This week's theme is this.
Anime to watch when you want to cry.
When you want to vent about stress
or want some stimulation,
perhaps some people might want to watch touching anime.
I would like to recommend you
touching anime that make you cry.
They're anime that strongly stimulate your mind,
which will make you cry to reset your emotions.
Let me share them with you.
Touching anime that make you cry.
Here is the first one.
ANOHANA: THE FLOWER WE SAW THAT DAY.
It's an anime that must be included in this theme.
Please don't say it's stereotyped.
Some of you may have only heard of the name
but haven't watched it yet.
Or maybe you've seen the scene of a girl crying,
or you know the song "Secret Base," which is used in the anime.
If you think any of the above is you,
then go watch it at once.
With romance as its axis,
answers to various doubts are revealed,
and there's a series of touching moments in the anime.
In the final episode,
there's a point that intensely makes you cry.
The opening song, "Aoi Shiori,"
was also written for this anime.
The melody is clear and sad,
and the lyrics reflect the feelings of the characters.
It's really wonderful.
After you watch the whole anime,
just listening to this song
is enough to make you cry.
The next touching anime I'll recommend that makes you cry is this.
VIOLET EVERGARDEN.
Please don't say this is stereotyped too.
This anime is just a continuous storm of touching moments.
The growth of its protagonist, Violet,
and heart-warming episodes of people around her are depicted,
expressing the love of people in various forms.
They make your eyes and heart cry.
After you finish watching this anime,
you'll realize again
that telling people how you feel, being kind, and loving people
are important in their own unique ways.
It has a touching story and animation you're going to love,
so you're going to be satisfied and cry for sure.
Next, I'll recommend anime that stimulate your mind
and make you cry with mixed feelings.
Here's the first one.
IN THIS CORNER OF THE WORLD.
During the World War, even when she had various troubles,
no matter how harsh the situation was,
by coming up with new ideas
and making effort on her way of life,
Suzu lives with a positive attitude.
It touches your heart and makes you cry.
It's easy to put yourself in protagonist Suzu's shoes.
You'll agree with Suzu's words and empathize with her when you watch it.
This is also the anime's characteristic.
Also, when I think about many people in this world
having actually experienced those things,
it makes me very sad.
"I should take the message of this anime seriously,"
I think.
This anime makes your various emotions gush out and makes you cry.
Next, it's this anime.
A SILENT VOICE.
There are many anime that use romance with people with a disablity as a theme,
but this anime specifically describes
the feelings of the person with a disability and the people around her.
It's very realistic.
There are heartbreaking scenes everywhere.
Protagonist Shoya Ishida's thoughts and actions
make you ponder all kinds of things.
Empathizing with the characters and pondering things
will make your heart ache.
There's sadness, pain, worry, and relief.
This anime really will stir your heart.
To be honest, even when you don't want to cry,
you should watch this anime at least once.
All of the anime I've introduced today
will make you cry very hard,
so please watch them when you want to feel refreshed.
That's it for Weekly Favorites.
N-ko's Monologue.
This part has no specific theme.
I'm just going to say what I think,
and it's very light-hearted.
Like things I've been thinking of and doing lately.
Or I'll talk about people I'm a big fan of.
It's a segment where we just talk freely.
This time,
I'm going to talk to you about the life hack I found.
We've been staying home a lot since last year, right?
I also work from home and just eat at home every day,
so when I'm busy with work
or when I don't want to prepare a meal,
I often just eat ready-made meals.
There have been times I ate ready-made meals since before this,
so I know various kinds of them.
But there are many high-quality ones available lately.
Among them,
I finally found the best combination of ready-made meals.
That is retort-pouch curry on oatmeal.
Oatmeal is healthy and chewy.
It goes very well with some spicy curry.
Even if you have no rice, if you have some oatmeal,
you can make curry rice!
I don't know if I can call it curry "rice" though.
I wanted to tell someone about this combination so much that I felt restless.
So I feel great that I've said it.
Please do try it yourself!
That's it for N-ko's Monologue.
N-ko's Q & A Section!
I will answer your questions again this week.
Let's start.
This is the first question.
Why are you a sheep?
Why are you a human being?
If you choose between two ninja anime,
do you like NINTAMA RANTARO or NARUTO more?
It's NARUTO!
Your favorite video game?
Apex Legends. I want to play in the tournament!
Do you feel any difference between American and Japanese cultures?
I think everything in America is big.
What's your favorite sweet?
Pudding!
Thank you for your questions.
I'm still waiting for you to send me your questions!
That's it for N-ko's Q & A.
The N-ko Show! It's now time to say goodbye.
I've introduced many touching anime today,
so please remember to keep yourself hydrated!
I'm going to explore the possibilities of cream stew and oatmeal
before next week.
Let's meet again next time.
See you!